はじめの混ぜる企画めちゃくちゃ面白くて
最高あの実はねぇ
俺も好きですよ
マズル聞くこんにちははじめ社長ですと
いうわけでやってまいりましたいちご味の
お菓子全部集めて混ぜたら何やすみああ
ああああ
というわけで前回はバター知能化しあずれ
たんですけどもあのちょっと1番地となる
と量がおかしいパターン3倍近くあるぞ
釣り今回もマジで全種類集めようと思って
家の近くのセブンローソンファミマとは
スーパー全部させましたこれが俺の地域に
ある5号のお菓子すべてでほぼ網羅して
あるはずざっと数えたらご一緒でぐらい
だったんですけどもみなさんよく考えてみ
てくださいいちご味のお菓子以上に多いと
いうことはこれすなわちん
15足が一番多いんですよ違うめっちゃて
ないこと言ってる馬鹿ピッチバージなお
菓子が一番美味しいんですよ要するにどの
お菓子も15ずにアレンジしたらおいしく
なるって分かってるから女だくさん市場者
の場所が出てしまっているようにつまり1
チャオれパターずよりおいしいんじゃない
かって言うか納税の権化ですよまじで本当
においしいねで3つ上のお菓子ってそれを
今回全部集めてきたので早速一つにまとめ
てみましょうかアルミ歩い
では早速食べさせていただきますいやー
右日できるな者数がに多すぎんくこんなに
多いんだ接触させていただきますまずは
王道でしょうコアラのマーチこれは俺なん
ならそこより1歩道が好きなんですよこれ
は街は色もちゃんとちょっとピークなん
ですよあります
5章山抜きでおいしいガラ紡つ船215誰
もの一番をねめっちゃ家が吹きがたら
止まんなくなるタイプなぜなんだよね
[音楽]
を
昨日ねまぁ一言のショコラこんな前に
決まっておろうがー
どんどんいちご&練乳であります宇宙
ポッキーつぶつぶいちご大きいいただき
ます
マールバンドストロベリーるーワールマン
と日分せてるのそんなのうまいに決まっ
取り合いと言います
もう果汁グミいちごぶどうと b 担い店
からさせているイチゴもありまして
いただきます
美味しい
うううう
グリーンズ刺し子風ウィッグマスター水圧
で読めないさん海外産のやつですね
ちょっとわかんないですけどそれで一号
だったから買ってみたんでがーうわぁ数号
でんか
ドロ団子みたいいただきます
ああああああ
うんもあ待って待って中にストロベリー
クリームが入っててるんやばいってこれ
これまたかいますでこんな前の夜中にあっ
たんだガーナショコラかね152手4倍
それを入りすぎだよいただきます
こういう脳子ですねもう一度チョコって
感じがすっげ攻めに出てる甘いリンクの声
だなずべリアと比べりってから
ストロベリーじゃねえじゃねえか
マイカーコレット今回除外させていただき
ます8月付いていきます塗る定義し
フルーティー濃い苺ビル t 喫茶靴の中
で撮ってるで有名ですからねいただきます
冬に食べたイメージストロベリー
チョコレートこれ年前で降りイメージあり
ますねってカズホス議員からいただきます
これもと売れてるイメージあるよな
う前
やばい
糖尿病になるとて部のゾーンに甘酸っぱい
いちごのザックザククランチちゃんはこれ
で滑ったりですけどへ母カティ系じゃねー
か
やりますちょうどいいこれだけで闘った
じゃんとかパー looper めっちゃ
スティー通学
ブーブー本音一応魅力一番きゃって言っ
たらこれ見たいチョイスか昔ちょっとして
たらいただきます
心理学100%とびきり1も全く新刊が来
て想像できないけど結構家財キャンディー
ですねいただきます
[音楽]
高15これはキャンディですねいただき
ます
[音楽]
株でも市場株価は一部若中上でも匹敵する
ぐらい前に使っていただきます
ん
来れば
冷や汗かいてきた俺今なくて大丈夫じゃば
威力てるとも続きいきますはい2ストロベ
in めっちゃ昔ハマってました親の顔
より官らずでスマ懐かしいただきます
この銀盤に会とれたことはガーナピンク
チョコレートダウンまあそうこんなあった
んだ教えてよーいただきました
ほどよい甘さです食べやすくランティス
トラベリーえっクラッキストーリーあんの
なんでもありや本土に毎日待ってろ
mature いいねこれは qb
ストロベリー qb 誰か手につきにくい
チョコレートねもう四角っぽいですね
いただきます
いちご慣れしすぎて味が少なくって一つ
大丈夫これこれチョコボの一番良い願いし
まーすそれでした
ビスコいちご味リスクを外して来ないと
さすがに羽毛直売苺とホイップクリーム
底ばい最中はめっちゃピンク色慰安婦て
いただきます
[音楽]
me
いっ
[音楽]
うまいんですけど大田がいっぱいで
ポンチョ一致バージパクジュヒョンカメラ
沿いセブンのいちご今チョコ早急に
ちょっとパウっとしてません第二リッチ
ストロベリーチョコレートサンドん
[音楽]
ええええええっ
me
gooちょっとあのこいつ後やばいなぁ
もうああああああっ提携いただきます
meああああああまあ経典な恋支援柴田
ショコラふらぽわーるなと高級そう先に恋
や作るためばよかったなぁうわぁめっ
チャート大きいのとなぐらいで外交部門
わぁいただきます
ええええええ
耳が深江
そしてこれらずべりーですね
ふざけんなあるほどフリーミアム
追い出せるラズベリーやないかもうなんか
ちょっとずつ商品減ってきている助かって
ますもうこれは欠かせないでしょアポロ
ちょもういちご味のお菓子といったら
ほんとこれでしょうねいただきました
変われない奴でスプレッドでショコラ
あのーいちご触れてちょっとなんか味に
ついてからが一望コーティングだけてる
だけでしょちょうどいい感じだったという
100てブログちんチョコビスケット遊ぶ
つシリーズに待ったつ15ございます
うわあああぽろ前スタイル大人の1両でお
砂糖25%多くらしいですよ
もう僕には何の意味もありませんいただき
ます
まあ美味しい普通していいのにでお砂糖
控えめだったらいいねはこれなんか無駄
さんただこういう犯すはめたような記憶が
ありますがいちごつみというお菓子です
めっちゃ昔食べた気がするわいただけます
懐かしい
アポロ恋とドイツの終わったまだ恋通るか
いっけいいただきます
おおあぁん
小井戸アルグラッドチョコレートを見た目
がクラッチカットでてますていただきまし
た上さぁさぁ15うわぁ
はーふ入っていただけだった
うわぁ
直感のしっとり15いただきますわーだ
けど過疎と一番のショコラわークリーム
玄米から1保ちつつあるといいじゃでっか
はぁっ
お尻やのストロベリープロメンこれはで
食ってたよく
馬ひどくて茶をいただきます
俺は俺タイマー砂糖ゼロ糖類ゼロ手が降り
建機は高齢俺昔砂糖ゼロストーリー何だと
ホントひとりで全部食べたら記憶あります
まるで意味なしています
すっかり落ちていくようなそれ giant
警護いちご味しん
[拍手]
[音楽]
ため
というわけで以前出塁し続く終わりました
それも来ませんちょっと多すぎるなあまり
荷物の秘匿事実しか食べてないんですけど
も動いを食べたもうおります自分の息が
10地方の味しますの塀というわけで早速
混ぜていきましょう強い所ピストンが
リボンガール
he
learned
to
doヤンヤンつけボー
シャア
これは凄いよまじであったの時と違って
本当の組とかちょっとクッキー雨完全に
バリエーションが幅広くなってます
果たしてどういう味になるのでしょうか
これじゃ圧を統一してまぜるなも美味しい
の拍手されますからあ sad を
おいしくなるくるすっごい気になる所です
ねええ
[音楽]
様式著
関西をしました
大
いちごの匂いだ早速盛り付けしていき
ましょう
写してだけなんですけど
[音楽]
完成しましたこちらがすべてのイチゴ味の
場所合体されで作った史上最強においしい
イチゴのお菓子でございます i 2に
完成してしまいましたいやー
ンジ使ったじゃなくなかった42種類から
相当座数だったからびっくりすぎた橋は感
すごい楽しみですね果たしてすべての15
の食舌舌鼓動カスどういう味がするん
でしょうか1ブロックこれでカラフルば
いいのもいただきました
くれる
dj
たr
ああ
アジュはからふざけてるわけじゃなくて
試食で食いすぎて本当にお腹いっぱいで今
マジ味がわからないからチョコとか
クッキーだけだったら多分皿からしてたん
ですけど今回組と雨とかちょっと年度が
あるものも混ざってるからいい感じでなく
湿った口どうなんだろう美味しい被って
ならないつってひょっとしたらそんなに
美味しくないのかもしれない俺の中で
程よくおいしいイチゴのなんかちょっと
クチャクチャしたおかしい三点60点
くらいかなと私は思っておりますとか私も
研究対象にはならないので新しい被験体
およびましょう
グリラカーがー
するします皆さんこれは連れてのいちごの
場所混ぜ合わせて作った史上最強に
おいしいイチゴのお菓子です四条西一
おいしいんですね
いただきますん
うーん
[音楽]
のん
美味しくないのかもしれあっ果てないし
あんまり
くってなくっても美味しいけどよくわかん
なかったなんかもんなんだレックって
えっ
遠い質問し砂利おいしい者においしい者
レベル4匹嫌い4匹がつきかというそれか
すけかでと好きスンホめでとうございます
やー
ん
[音楽]
eleanor